[Music]
one of the world's most influential
businessmen is taking on the government
over its coronavirus lockdown Elon Musk
says on Twitter he has reopened his
factory in California in violation of
local government orders chief
correspondent Jonathan hunt has the
latest after waiting for weeks against
California's restrictions on
manufacturing Elon Musk restarted
production at his California plant on
Monday tweeting quote I will be on the
line with everyone else if anyone is
arrested I ask that it only be me with
the Tesla factory shutdown revenue
obviously is falling fast
while other auto companies are reopening
production lines among them Toyota in
Indiana today General Motors Ford and
Fiat Chrysler in Michigan either late
this week or early next but officials in
Alameda County California like many in
the Bay Area are moving slowly arguing
Tesla first needs to show it can operate
safely California governor Gavin Newsom
backed those County health officials
today but said he believed progress is
being made by belief and hope and
expectation is as early as next week
they will be able to resume but Tesla
has filed a lawsuit in federal court
accusing the Alameda County Health
Department of overstepping federal and
state restrictions while Elon Musk once
again took to Twitter Saturday writing
quote frankly this is the final straw
Tesla will now move its HQ and future
programs to Texas / Nevada immediately
California assembly woman and former
labor leader
Lorena Gonzalez fired back with this
succinctly musk replied message received
experts say that while musk may want to
move production out of California it
would cost a fortune and take anywhere
from 12 to 18 months musk certainly has
the money those same experts argue but
does he have the time Brett Jonathan
thank you